很简单的一个逻辑，
他如果爱你，
怎么忍心让你当地下情人？
当了三年，
他明明能够感受得到，
就是周围有人的时候，
他还得当一个老板一样对你颐指气使的，
他明明能感受到你的委屈，
但是他就忽略你的委屈，
这就是不爱你。
姐姐。
我是00年的大专毕业生，
我是一名销售，
我的存款有90万，
我的底薪是1万，
我的收入大多数是来自于我的销售提成，
是一个很拼命干活的销售。
然后第二，
我的对象是我的老板，
她到我15岁，
85年的本科学历，
在深圳有房有车，
她是离异，
有个十来岁的女儿，
我平均一年可以给他至少50万的毛利。
我们一直都是地下恋，
同事四年，
在一起三年，
公司是没有人知道我们在一起的，
有同事同行的人在的时候，
我们就和普通的上下属一样，
但是独处的时候我们才会牵手，
像情侣一样。
年初我因为这个地下恋的原因，
我不想继续在一起，
我想分手，
但是他不同意，
就挽留我了，
他平时也是不同意我看他手机的，
他在外界别人也都以为他是单身的，
这一点是我内心最记忆的一个地方。
现在要说到一个更重要的一点，
就是他前妻的事情，
就是他平时会说他前妻是个疯子，
小孩很小的时候他就分开了，
大五六年了吧，
他会精彩因为小孩之前吵架，
比如说。
前期给小孩报了补习班，
没有尊重他的时间安排，
或者说因我对象签一些协议，
如果对象不签，
他就会告到当地的那个社区的民警那里去，
或者说因为接触小孩的事情，
在补习班门口对小孩的奶奶动手打人，
这以就是他前妻的一个人格。
现在我要问的问题是，
我们在一起快三年了，
他从未主动提过要结婚，
去年我下定决心说要分手，
因为我不可能跟他一直这样子立下恋，
一直玩这个游戏，
然后他说OK，
我可以结婚，
他说明年可以跟我结婚，
就是今年了答应我的事情。
但是到现在他也没有提到结婚的事情，
春节没有说去见我爸妈跟母亲，
就是对他这个态度很不满意，
我爸妈不知道他大这么多啊，
我跟他们是大10岁，
你感受大15岁啊，
我觉得差不多，
我就说一个这么成熟的男人，
如果没有主动来表态，
那就说明他这个人不正常，
他的态度不端正，
他的恋爱观跟我们不匹配。
我父母是希望我分手的，
但是他不强求我，
他们不看好这段关系，
所以我第一个问题就是龙飞姐说你是我，
你应该怎么做，
然后我还有另外第二个问题，
我也质疑过两个问题，
我第一个问题就是他这个女儿会不会像他前妻一样那么的刁蛮，
我们以后的相处会不会很困难，
以及我以后的生活会不会因为他前妻啊变得鸡飞狗跳，
我跟他说我要发现一个小孩，
他说OK，
那我们的小孩会不会因为他对他原本这个女儿的黑？
更感而陪伴我们自己小孩的时间更少了呢，
爱更少了呢，
是真心喜欢他的，
但是如果我要真的先跟他进一步推进关系的话，
我要怎么提前去和他约定，
去避免这种事情发生呢？
我算一笔账啊，
你在这里工作总共是四年，
对不对，
对啊，
那你的以你自己的销售，
你自己算账，
你这四年为公司创造了多少利润，
钱哪里，
除去我的提成，
除去我的底薪，
应该给他赚了有200万以上，
嗯，
所以说你自己的能力是在的，
他底解他不同意，
对，
不是说基于你和这个男人，
到这个男人多给你钱了，
你放在哪里都能挣到这个钱，
都能追为这个销售的提成，
那么这个男人并没有给你额外的经济上的，
比如说更多的钱，
因为你的提成肯定是单位有制度的，
公司肯定是有制度的提成的规则的，
对你这个部门由我来开拓这个市场，
是比较早进来的那一个，
所以他给我的提成制度会比现在的人高，
我以前的提成制度可以高到30%，
现在的人只能拿到10~15，
以及他给我的更多福利是比如说我们会出国的机会，
他会优先给我，
而不是给别人，
只有这些了，
客户资源因为都是我开发的，
所以都掌握在我手上，
那如果我是你的话，
哦，
我可能不会选择那么复杂的婚姻关系，
因为他说他前期是。
疯子，
他前妻跟他的妈妈处的也不好，
在幼儿园门口能打架的那种，
他前妻现在还会出现那种对他有提各种各样的要求，
在我的生命当中的话，
我感觉我不愿意跟任何一个不理性的人有什么沾亲带故，
这是我个人的观点，
反正我自己也能挣钱呀，
我在哪也能吃上这碗饭啊，
我在哪也能挣到这个钱呀，
我不愿意把我的人际关系对于一种风险的境地，
我的人际关系当中没有那种疯子，
没有那种极端主义的，
没有那种说要死要活到2，
要打生打死的，
我活这一辈子啊，
好不容易赶上这么好的历史时机，
我能够平平安安的活到老，
我能够衣食无忧的活到老，
我还不愿意我自己生命当中有这样一个人，
你这个还算好的，
你知道吗？
我之前还接触过一个妹妹，
她也是找了一个比他大一点的男的，
这男的各方面都很好，
他们俩很相爱，
但这个男的有一个前期是偏职人格，
什么叫偏职人格呢？
就算他俩离了，
他也觉得我对这个男人有一定的掌控力，
我为什么能掌控这个男人呢？
我的孩子在我手上也可深可辅，
我对这个男人有绝对的掌控力，
就什么时候叫这个男的干什么事儿，
她就得去，
不然的话她是要死要活的。
然后那个妹妹就问我，
红飞姐，
这种情况下我很爱这个男人，
我该怎么办？
没有那个男人值得我把我的社会关系，
将来我要是有小孩。
啊，
多了一个质子，
没有哪个男人值得我把我的人际关系放在这样一个偏执的人旁边，
你生的孩子难免会跟他的前妻相处的，
因为两个孩子要相处，
逢年过节了都有可能是要见面的，
不可能说这辈子你生的孩子和他的前妻，
和他前妻生的小孩儿都不见面，
这是不可能的。
但往往那种控制欲很强的偏执的人格养出来的孩子的话，
他要么很悲惨，
要么就是很变态，
他前妻就是控制力很强，
但我这个对象呢，
就是放手让小孩对着他发展，
不会管他太多，
而且这男的也不爱你，
大家都这么说，
所以没有必要，
完全没有必要。
你那么年轻，
你什么哪可就能马上看出来了呢？
你都不知道生活的细节，
很简单的一个逻辑，
他如果爱你，
怎么忍心让你当地下情人？
当了3年，
他明明能够感受得到，
就是周围有人的时候，
他还得当一个老板一样对你颐指气使的，
他明明能感受到你的委屈，
但是他就忽略你的委屈，
这就是不爱你。
嗯，
知道，
我感觉你说完这个跟个问题都不需要你解答了，
我很恐惧，
但是我又很喜欢他，
但是你经历的男人少，
因为我每次他分手，
他都死皮赖脸跑到我家门口不让我发，
那我真的要跟他推进一下步，
我给怎么去确保我以后的生活不会因为他前期变得鸡飞狗跳呢？
确保不了，
因为他前期是一个不可控的因素。
除非你俩出国，
跟前妻不在一个国家，
嗯，
是妈妈控制不了，
谢谢姐姐，
好，
那就这样啊，
我直播间应该也有那种年轻的姑娘，
刚进入职场的时候，
就会被这种结过婚了，
生过小孩儿的，
离过异的男人，
很容易被人家拿捏，
但是你们跳出来的之后就会看到本质，
本质就是这个男的一方面觉得这个女孩能为我挣钱，
我得稳住你，
我说句话很难听，
甚至有的男的就是为了稳住这些摇钱树，
然后给你们造成一些错觉，
他对你有感情，
他对你不一样，
他对你有偏爱，
这叫育人之术，
当老板的人都应该懂，
我直播间有没有看当老板的，
当老板的应该懂我说什么，
他为了能够把你这个摇钱树，
为了能够榨取你的利益，
他会给你一种错觉，
他对你跟别人是不同的，
他对你是感情跟别人是不同的，
记得点赞关注哦。